let me start off by saying by the way
cuz I realized I've never talked about
this and it's just a side note but um
something I really love about this show
is the opening and I know that's like
why this episode talked about there's no
reason oh but I just really won't point
out one of the things I really adore
about this show I mean if the openings
good it sets up everything really nice
but the one element that I love and I
swear to god of Rob would stone me this
too we both laugh our asses off whenever
you see an get that little wind ball a
writer ugly hahahaha ice max into that
statue something about the way that is
animated and the sound effect is perfect
to have in that opening and I'm glad
that was a permanent part of the opening
and it always makes us laugh our asses
off so just I know it's a weird side
note to talk about but I mean just
kudos to really good opening I'm really
funny because that shows very early on
that the show will take itself very
seriously it has a lot of weight
but Scott's really good funny moments
too because that was a I can watch that
a million times I'm wondering if there's
like a ten-hour loop up against the
statue there at whatever base made that
but if not somebody make it so um now
I'm gonna get like 20 people sending me
links to and well regardless
um okay so we got the swamp is this
episode and I have to be honest this is
the first time I've seen an avatar
episode where I didn't know what to
think of it partly because you don't
know if this stuff is going to come back
or this is self contained if it's self
contained it's a bit of a it's bit of a
mess a lot of stuff doesn't quite go
into where it's like oh here's a bit of
philosophy here's a bit of action here's
a bit of new characters the Blue Spirit
comes back for a bit um next episode so
if this stuff is going to come back it
will be interesting because I like to
see it explored if not like I so we go a
little bit philosophy a little bit of
action some characters uh but out over
really quite
came together per se because there's
some heavy dramatic moments in this to
with seeing like Osaka seeing his lost
love and you got Katara seeing her dead
mother and the question of who is the
the two people will want I think once a
person wants an animal that Aang saw so
if you know or will see so it seems like
they're building a lot of stuff up for
later but it's kind of it's a big tease
if that's the case which isn't bad you
know because it does ask what what is
going on here and that's fun for the
audience to to ask there we get a little
bit more of Zuko and his uncle um
begging mostly which I like seeing I in
a sense that like seeing Zuko really
have to like the kid hasn't suffered
enough but I like him going from this
incredible position of power down to
pretty much the lowest of the low in the
sense I mean down to even stealing
people that helped them like stealing
they're essentially their horse so but
on top of that a level that even he
finds hard to bear because I think
that's hard for the uncle to go for
stealing the animal but I think it's
hard for Zuko to go through begging it
seems like that's really something that
would affect him and he would despise
and he does there's a scene where a guy
says he'll give a gold coin in theack
old dances and sings and the uncle does
it not really thinking that much of it
maybe even a little too optimistic
honestly or a little too happy because
literally the guy is hitting his feet
and the uncle is trying to dance and he
gives him the gold coin and the uncle
says what a nice man it may be that was
supposed to be sarcastically even if it
was he seemed even for the uncle that
seemed a little to turn the other cheek
I mean again this guy is in the Fire
Nation er was uh you know he was like
leaving commands and sighs so that that
was a little strange but I guess that's
part of the fun of the character too is
that he can take something that's just
so terrible and find something that's
smile about
yes so yeah there's elements I like the
fact that the swamp was all one big tree
I thought that was really cool that's a
great idea
I like we sort of get this world's
interpretation of rednecks it seems like
it's what they do when they're trying to
find these instruments that sound close
to a banjo and try to have fun with it I
I like the fact that if you weren't you
have to sort of wait for how they speak
and what they say in order to figure out
what their satirizing I kind of like you
wouldn't exactly get it right away from
their clothing you wouldn't necessarily
because they have like these leaf hats
and not much else you wouldn't
necessarily get oh that's like a redneck
thing or the hippies from a few episodes
before you would necessarily get they're
hippies until they start talking so I
kind of like that it's not like this is
a pure satire we're gonna mock
everything you still so see this
progression that this is how they
evolved in this world so I like that uh
and we get again we get some ideas again
we saw out of how water bending can work
a little bit more you can sort of put
the water through the leaves and you can
raise that up um which is kind of
interesting how do they freeze the water
by the way that's um a little curious
about um now why there's gonna be like a
million people in the comments say like
this is how they do it I got a lot of
flack for the moon thing by the way
which is it's not respect probably
deserved uh if you get its ID forget
about the gravitational pole which is
pretty obvious I'm talking about the
siege of the north I say oh why does the
moon totally knock out their power which
I to me it's still kind of a question
cuz they do have the water and I can see
it making them weaker but why take away
their power but then again the moon sort
of moves the tide its are like the
movement of the water so that makes a
little bit more sense but then how does
the Fire Nation make the fire well maybe
they'll go into that and that's that's
both the brilliance and the frustration
of this show is that you don't know what
they're going to go into
- and unlike lost I most of the people
no know how it ends and the show is
still seeing is very favorable and very
good and everything kinda comes back so
I do have to put a lot of trust in the
show what she's not bad and on top of
that I like how even if I say hey they
should answer this should answer this
it's just a great chance for me to look
like a dumbass when they do answer in a
future episode either it was all planned
or maybe they back then people were
complaining hey you should answer this
and they're like I was our plan all
along even though they probably just got
feedbacks from focus groups or something
so yeah again overall with this episode
I know those reviews can have been
everywhere but it was it was okay it'll
be better if it all does tie together
we'll be interesting to see this is the
beginning of a lot of elements but if
not it's just kind of clunky but still
interesting you know interesting clunky
so yeah I like I said it's hard to know
what to say about because I don't know
where it's going to go and this show has
a habit of sometimes tying it all back
together and other times just yeah that
serve when and did that so that's about
it and I shall see you guys at the next
episode take care